[Music]
we have won the Great War now we will
win the last war
rip her out fruit and stem hey guys Pete
here this will be my Game of Thrones
Season eight episode for official
trailer breakdown I'm still processing
how episode 3 played out but I wanted to
get this video done before I dig back
into that it's actually pretty exciting
because we finally get to see what the
back half which happens to be the longer
half of the season looks like my initial
thoughts were they pumped up the look of
King's Landing the set looks a lot
bigger much in the same way we saw them
do it Winterfell there were a lot of
images of the construction of the set
out there during filming and it's nice
to see how this looks on screen the
other thing that stood out on the first
watch was how both queens look pretty
self satisfied or smug and most of the
shots I doubt this as a feeling that
they will both be holding on to and it
seems like they chose to show us that
side for a reason let's look at it all
and break it down scene by scene and
then we'll talk about the big picture
the trailer opens with smoke and we
learned that they are burning the dead
outside of Winterfell it's a reminder of
what just happened there and how many
people fell defending the stark family
stronghold
we had the King's Landing next and get a
shot of Cersei looking out of a window
we see the castle walls and people
milling around below zooming in on the
crowd doesn't reveal much but based on
what we know is happening we can make a
guess that this is showing us that their
troops are looking a lot better than
what's left in the north the camera
angle changes and we see a shot of her
from the front and see that Iran is by
her side she looks confident and he
looks like he's impressed with the
spectacle back in the north we see some
unsullied filing out of the Winterfell
yard and some battle cleanup and repairs
happening sonses looking into the yard
but we can only guess as to what's going
on since she's out of focus and looking
the other way in the next shot we see
the stark sisters looking worn out from
the battle it's not surprising
considering what they just went through
I would imagine this is directly after
the battle before they go burn the
bodies as we're looking at them Daenerys
his voiceover starts she says we have
won the great war now we will win the
last war there is an accompanying shot
of JA
that matches what we see with our en
Santa we noticed their battle scars and
empty looking expressions after John we
cut to Daenerys and see her finish what
she's saying at first I thought this was
a continuous shot and thought it looked
like Danny recovered from the battle
much faster than everyone else when I
looked at it again it looks more like
she's inside either way she's addressing
the people has no sunde and Varys at her
side and looks ready to move on to the
next war the following scene looks like
a celebration and it looks like the
Dragon Queen has won over the surviving
lords and ladies who are in attendance
this is a big turnaround to the way
things were looking in episode 2 and
this seems like the right time to
mention that it looks like John isn't
pressing his claim in this trailer
everything we see looks like Daenerys is
taking her role in moving forward as if
his parentage reveal hasn't changed
anything I suppose that makes sense
since he did bend the knee to her but I
doubt this will stay a secret for long
there's another quick shot of Daenerys
at the Dragon's nest or is it a dragon's
lair
not sure what to call the area where her
dragons hang out actually there are two
shots at this location and this one just
looks like she's checking up being a mom
there may be something else going on
here but I don't see it Arion Gendry
both made it out of the battle alive and
we see them sharing a kiss maybe
something more is in the future for
these two I definitely had a feeling
ginjury was gonna be a goner based on
episode 2 and was on the edge of my seat
every time they showed him in the battle
when the whites were running amok inside
of Winterfell but yeah they're safe and
sound and they're sharing a kiss and who
knows what's gonna happen with them
outside we see Daenerys grey worm John
Sansa Arya and a few others carrying
torches out to burn the dead bodies
they're piled up all over the place we
can see most of the survivors in this
shot including ghost which I wasn't sure
about when I made my last video I had a
ton of comments telling me that he was
spotted in the trailer so it's good to
see that he's actually there I think you
might even be able to see Yan Royce in
this shot who didn't have any scenes in
the long night that I can remember but
yeah they're burning bodies and the shot
makes plain the REE
that it looks like a lot more of the
people that were lined up in front of
Winterfell before the battle ended up in
that pile rather than made it back alive
we got our first glimpse of this in
Melisandre final scene and I do wonder
about where her body and her glamour
ended up there's a quick shot of
Daenerys walking in the crypts by
herself from the way the lighting is it
makes it look like her eyes are teared
up as she goes by her facial expression
also looks as if she might be trying to
hold in her emotions but there's no
context to go off so I'll just leave it
there next we see reg I'll fly over a
ship with Targaryen sails it's a cool
looking shot and I imagine they're
heading to Dragonstone it cuts to Cersei
and Euron with creepy Qyburn in the
background
Euron goes down to one knee and his
facial expression makes it look like a
proposal rather than anything else I
didn't mention it before but there's a
lot of talk of Cersei being the final
boss now that the night king is dead and
it's worth mentioning that she
definitely looks like a boss in this red
dress like most people I doubt that
she's still pregnant with Jamie's baby
and she doesn't look pregnant at all in
this trailer to me after that we see
Sansa watching both dragons flying
overhead we can see that they both made
it out of the battle alive and that
Ragle has some damage to his wings Santa
has a concerned look on her face when we
see it and this feels like she's
watching John and Daenerys Lee for the
South leave for Dragonstone
in the next shot we look at John and
Davos riding out of Winterfell with
Gilly and torment looking on behind them
when I first saw this I thought maybe he
was going off on some kind of diplomatic
mission but it seems pretty unlikely
when you think it through considering
they're in the north and everybody's
traveling south anyways we see the
Targaryen ship sailing south and a shot
of Daenerys standing in front of drogon
then we get what I think is the most
peculiar shot of the trailer with Cersei
where she appears to be on the deck of a
ship we hear the final voiceover from
Daenerys who says we'll rip her out root
and stem this is a familiar phrase we've
heard a couple times before arya said it
as she was wearing walter freights face
as she was poisoning everyone
in the dining hall pointing out that
they should have killed all the Starks
beerus also used this expression when he
was telling tyrion about being cut
but yes Cersei looks forever confident
with your on in the mountain to her side
you can see King's Landing in the
distance and they do seem to be sailing
so the trailer ends there and the big
takeaway is that things are moving south
Daenerys and John's forces are depleted
but she appears to have won over the
people in the north
Sansa who would be staying behind looks
concerned and who can blame her she
knows what they're up against with
Cersei this episode is nearly as long as
the long night at seventy nine minutes
and Miguel supports Nick said in an
interview with E W that episodes three
four and five are like a single story
with a beginning middle and end it sure
looks like this middle episode will
involve moving everyone into place for a
battle in King's Landing in Episode five
the actual length of the episode gives
us some time to linger in the north
before they actually leave and it
definitely leaves some time for us to
figure out what Cersei has planned I
have a feeling that there's a lot we're
not seeing in this trailer but it's
really hard to figure out what it is
considering we haven't seen anything
beyond the first three episodes and
trailers except for that short scene at
Dragonstone that would indicate to me
that there's going to be a discussion
between John and Daenerys about how
things move forward it looked tense but
we don't know for sure that that fits
into this episode because there's no
reference I think that when we see
Cersei on the ship that it means that
there's going to be some kind of a
meeting there's really no good reason
for her to leave King's Landing
otherwise of course as Daenerys and John
get set up at Dragonstone with their
remaining forces that puts them a lot
closer to King's Landing like right next
door and if it wasn't for the Dragons
they'd be pretty vulnerable in that
position the stage is set we see where
things are headed in the Commons of my
last video a lot of people were pointing
out I mentioned that I thought that was
a divisive episode and it has turned out
to be that people are really split on
how they feel about
night king dying Aria being the one to
do it you name it puzzling in a way to
figure out how they're going to really
up the stakes for the showdown in
episode 5 I mentioned this in previous
videos that I can imagine ways they can
make Cersei the big bad and they can
make this payoff but there has to be
something that we don't quite see yet so
I'm hopeful that the story is headed in
the right direction I don't think it's
impossible that this could work out it
just depends on what we actually see on
the screen
Cersei has set herself up to be a
top-shelf villain it's just that we saw
them fighting the army of the Dead and
how will the golden company actually
compare to that I'm excited to see I'm
not that worried and I'm interested to
hear about what you guys think is going
to get set up in this episode you think
there's any treachery in store here that
we're not seeing in the trailer how do
you think that do you think it's as odd
as I do that they're showing them
looking so smug they both can't win let
me know what you think in the comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel to follow
along I plan on doing a full recap and
review of episode 3 next I do have to
travel and fly home tomorrow so we'll
see how that all plays out as long as
the schedule work I'm definitely going
to watch episode 3 again and give it
another look through new eyes and that's
it for today thanks for watching I will
talk to you soon